[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
happy indigenous people's day
[ __ ] Christopher Columbus
[Music]
[ __ ] them
oh should I take a half an hour and ask
why we still believe the nonsense about
Christopher Columbus
and by we I mean not that many people
most people have discovered that oh yeah
he discovered the Americas
not America
and he was a genocidal piece of [ __ ] see
this morning Italian Americans is
trending as well because they're still
part of Italian Americans who celebrate
Columbus because he was Italian the
weird part about that
is that Christopher Columbus
did not come to America he came to the
Caribbean and also
he was Italian but he
he
sailed here under the Spanish crown
under a different crown
and when he got here well we all know
what he did
we all know what he did
which was what conquerors did then
which doesn't make it any better
but it doesn't mean that we have to
celebrate him
it doesn't I mean we can study him
you can study the facts you can study
the history you could know the truth
that's [ __ ] perfectly fine there's
nothing wrong with knowing the truth we
have founding fathers in this country
who who were on a mission
to be free
but they were slave owners you
understand
yes history is complicated
it's very complicated especially when
you put it in today's context
this is why these megalodites get so
turned around and twisted in their
brains and I'm gonna show you this [ __ ]
today
oh buddy do I have evidence of a
disease-ridden country
now it's a small percentage
we talked about this before it's a small
percentage but these [ __ ] are
gonna go vote
and there's others that are going to
capitulate to these dumb [ __ ]
that are gonna go vote
but this is what happens
and there's no perfect day than today to
see it right out in the open
about how we cannot come to grips
with reality today
in 2022 October 10th
if we can't even get a grip can't even
[ __ ] get a grip on who Christopher
Columbus was
and what he did
it's really [ __ ] weird
when I was a kid in school they would
teach us that Christopher Columbus is
the one who discovered America
in 1492 Columbus sailed the ocean blue
that's what they that's how they got you
to memorize the [ __ ]
they also taught you about Johnny
Appleseed
Washington cutting down the cherry tree
all kinds of [ __ ] nonsense
you know
too institutionalize this country an
Institutional and for people like me
it's enough of the [ __ ] really it's
enough of it it really is enough
we're smart enough
and gosh darn it People Like Us
it really it really we don't need the
[ __ ] anymore
we don't need to [ __ ] our children
we don't need to [ __ ] each other
and you know what if people want to
celebrate Christopher Columbus because
he happens to be Italian fine whatever I
mean Jesus Christ these [ __ ]
megalodites dozens of them show up in
the middle of the [ __ ] desert
to hail their golden calf their false
idol Donald Trump
it's really [ __ ] pathetic
but it's getting dangerous as [ __ ]
and here's why it's getting dangerous as
[ __ ]
because there's only a few of them
there's only a few of them left
that are going to sycophant
for this son of a [ __ ]
this criminal this crook this con man
there's only a few left and that's what
makes it so goddamn dangerous
because they're absolutely [ __ ]
delusional
off the rails completely
they're all fart no [ __ ] literally all
foam no beer whatever phrase you want to
give it
off the reservation they are out to
lunch folks
these people have lost their their minds
forget about forget about trying to talk
to them about indigenous people in
Arizona
and where the border of Mexico used to
be forget about trying to explain to
Kerry Lake why there are so many Mexican
Americans that live in her State forget
about trying to explain that to her
hey dummy
parts of your region used to be Mexico
it really is [ __ ] ridiculous that we
even have to explain this to these
[ __ ] let alone trying to
[ __ ] convince them that Christopher
Columbus wasn't a founding father
yeah
I don't even know how you start the
conversation
these people think Michael Jackson and
Tupac are still alive
and we're supposed to [ __ ] try to
figure out how to undo the
institutionalism of Christopher Columbus
it really is it really is
a very important moment in our country's
history
right now not not 1492. I mean that too
and then the truth there is an important
moment of what actually happened
to know the truth and to know who
Columbus was and what he did but right
now this is one of the most important
moments
and can we use
can we use the conversation of Columbus
and Indigenous people today to trying to
unwind some of this stuff maybe
maybe it's a way
but I say it every single day on here
Monday through Friday
for two full hours the way that you're
going to change this you
who are listening
you are going to have to lean into your
democracy
you gotta lean all the way the [ __ ] in
even though I'm gonna show you this [ __ ]
today and you're like how in the [ __ ] do
these people even expect to win like
Kerry Lake
Tommy tuberville holy [ __ ] that racist
piece of [ __ ] Marjorie Taylor green
talking about white replacement she's a
white nationalist she's a [ __ ] Nazi
okay it's they're not even it's right
out in the open now
and then you have this other [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] who's running for
Secretary of State
and he's got a band a secretary's
Estates that are going to overturn your
elections they're going to steal your
democracy and they're saying it out loud
they're saying it out loud right out in
the open we're going to steal your
democracy and make it an autocracy we
are going to Crown Trump King is what
they're saying we're going to make him
our Jesus he is going to be our leader
the mango Mussolini they're saying it
right out in the open
believe them
it is a serious moment we're 28 days I
believe two weeks
or two weeks four excuse me four weeks I
can't do math it's Monday I've only had
a couple cups of coffee give me a
[ __ ] break
four weeks we are four weeks away
as of tomorrow
if there's early voting if if you need
to check your registration the time is
now now is the time
some places are already starting early
voting if you have one of them
fraudulent mail-in ballots get that
[ __ ] going
foreign
ERS in mountains of votes
it is crucial it is important for you to
lean into your democracy now right now
don't wait four weeks
and get everyone you know to lean in
if you have three people if you help
three people check their registration
and they help three people
foreign
's gonna win this that's what's going to
win this for democracy
and it's going to create a situation
where the Democrats win the Senate
the Democrats win the house they win
several Governor uh braces that are
going to be totally out of blue out of
the blue
we can do this
it is a possibility
it's just a matter of three just three
three year community members family
friends make sure they check their
registration
if they can early vote go do that let's
do it now let's sink this son of a [ __ ]
right now
if you can if you need to request a
mail-in ballot if you need one of them
for all Gene ballots that they don't
like
[ __ ] Em Get It vote now is the time
to win this election now four weeks out
we only got four weeks
so get three people and commit them to
get three people
and so on and so on and it will build
trust me
you can't relent because again I'm gonna
show you today this footage from this
[ __ ] rally and everyone's like oh the
[ __ ] rallies they don't matter yes
they do
yes they [ __ ] do yes it's not gonna
win them elections but they're telling
you what the [ __ ] they're gonna do
they're saying it out loud how they're
gonna steal your democracy how they're
going to take away your vote
they're saying it right in front of a
microphone
in front of you know dozens of people
there but they're recording it
and broadcasting it
it's the quiet part way the [ __ ] out
loud
I believe
I believe that it's going to go over
like a wet fart and a white thong
because I am very confident that
Americans in this country are not going
to be told what the [ __ ] to do not only
that
they're not gonna put up with someone
trying to take away their [ __ ] rights
they're just not
and they're not going to be put up with
being treated like they're [ __ ]
stupid like with this gas price thing
what
OPEC is the reason why fuel prices are
going to change OPEC
and the reason why we have reserves in
place to try to fend off
any kind of [ __ ] assault that OPEC
would an economic assault that OPEC
would have on our democracies and
democracies around the world
is because we have an Administration
that's put that's made sure we have
plenty of reserves and plenty of
production in this country
that's that's the reason why because we
have [ __ ] adults in charge
so
as you get caught up today
with
some dumb [ __ ]
thinking that Christopher Columbus is a
founding father because I'm telling you
it's gonna happen
I run into one of these some [ __ ]
today
you're gonna run into one
they they think he wrote the Declaration
of Independence of some [ __ ]
you don't think so you don't think I'm
tell I'm telling you there are there are
[ __ ] people out there in this country
that vote okay they're going to vote who
think Christopher Columbus signed the
Declaration of Independence and he
founded America I ain't [ __ ] you
I wouldn't you're my favorite turd why
would I do that
yeah
it exists
and you know who you know them hell you
may like them you may think they're a
smart person
and they believe that [ __ ]
I know you're saying Tony there's no way
anyone I know believes that yes
yes there is yes there is
yes that's the whole point of
institutionalizing this stuff
is get people to believe [ __ ] that just
is not even close to the truth
and you're gonna see it on video
of some dumb [ __ ]
not even knowing
not even knowing that they'll be the
first to go
but they will allow it to happen
that's how fascism works
that's how fascism works why would why
would when a fascist regime takes over
and destroys a government okay think
about this for a second why would a
fascist regime
when they take over government
get rid of its most loyal
soldiers
because those are the people those are
the soldiers that help them overthrow
the last government
why would they want to keep them around
overthrow the next government once they
find out what the hell the actual
government is going to be
the first thing Adolf Hitler did was
when he gained power
in Germany the first thing
and she started murdering the essay
which is the brown shirts as everyone
you know knows them as
they were the Violent ones
they were the ones that tried to
overthrow the government
he went after them first because they
were violently trying to overthrow
governments and he was trying to have a
government where he didn't want to be
overthrown as a dictator
this is what they do
this is what they do
and that's why they're trying to stoke
violence they're trying to stoke fear
but fear not
fear not
you still have the right to vote and yes
I know some states are hard to vote in
Texas being one of them Georgia being
another but you must you must crawl over
hot coals and large shards of glass if
you must
it is crucial
our way of life depends on it here in
this country
I'm going to prove it to you today just
with a few clips that come out of this
rally
folks it [ __ ] matters
sunlight is the best disinfectant I got
I we I repost these videos right on my
Twitter and some people are like why are
you why are you posting this why are you
showing this why are people even
listening to these folks still
they're [ __ ] serious they're dead
serious
and taking away your way of life
and they're Relentless they are not
going anywhere
and delusion has a hold of these
[ __ ] especially
the head idiot
he stood on stage Let me Give an example
before we go because we're gonna watch
the clips but let me give you an example
Grandpa Poopypants stood on stage he
said in one breath
that yes I took documents yes I had all
the documents and boxes and boxes of
documents of course I did why wouldn't I
they're mine
and then the next breath he said all
that stuff was planted
folks it can't be both
it can't be both
and I don't I don't you know there's a
degree of me that thinks well he knows
what he's doing
he knows what I don't I don't know
anymore
I can't tell anymore what's what's what
is what he believes and what stupidity
and what's gaslighting
you gotta remember this guy is full on
reading and believing Q Anon
and Q Anon is back and it's in full
force and these [ __ ] are
believing every single bit of it and and
they are idolizing him
it's a [ __ ] disease
and he's the main cancer that's gonna
kill the country
he's the he's it's metastasized to him
and they they're desperate they're
getting desperate
and they're in and they they painted
themselves into so many [ __ ] corners
here
it's dangerous
the smaller and smaller and smaller his
following his loyalist most loyal
following gets the more dangerous it
becomes
because there is a there is an end here
there's an end to this nonsense
at some point
we see this in any cult moving movement
any any cult movement has an end and
it's a dramatic one
and the reason why is because
of exactly what we're seeing right in
front of us they're desperate the
movement is getting smaller and smaller
more people are are
leaving the movement
waking up being woke they're wokers
those mother walkers
if you've ever watched any kind of uh
documentary on Jonestown
and Jim Jones
and you listen because they have
recordings of him over the intercom
at Jonestown he would get on the
intercom and he would pump lies into
these people's brains with a microphone
and what he would do is convince these
people
that he was basically their God and that
everyone else was against him and that
made them the enemy
that's literally what this [ __ ]
is saying he is basically repeating what
James Jones was saying on the intercom
Dana Jones down but he sang it to his
entire National following
dangerous [ __ ] [ __ ]
because again they're getting smaller
and smaller and smaller
which means it's only getting down to
the nitty-gritty here we're only getting
down to the people who believe every
single thing Hook Line Sinker and are
not [ __ ] Tethered to any sort of
reality whatsoever they are about to
drink the Kool-Aid is what I'm saying
the Kool-Aid moment is coming folks
it's coming
and I I'm not sure if the Kool-Aid
moment is November 8th the election I
don't know
now I think it's actually past that
point
because they truly believe there's going
to be this huge Red Wave Jesus Christ
are trending it on Twitter
that that that somehow Republicans are
going to take the Senate and the house
and they're gonna they're gonna make
Donald Trump the speaker and they're
gonna they're gonna impeach Biden and
Harris at the exact same time which is
not the way it works and then and then
they're gonna appoint Donald Trump the
president King of the United States he's
dictator or some stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] that
our Constitution doesn't even do
this [ __ ] Secretary of State
nominee saying that he's got secretaries
the state center willing to overturn
elections that is not how it works
that's not that's not how state
constitution Works state constitution
does not give the power to secretaries
of state to overturn elections that is
not a thing
now they will try to use any law they
can to steal away any votes that they
can and to steal in the elections that
they can inside that Constitution but
there is nowhere in this country that
gives one person
there is not a listen to me there is not
a constitutional provision in this
country that gives one person one
individual no matter what office it is
the absolute power to determine an
entire election
that is not how it [ __ ] works
but they believe it is
so when these people try it when they
try the thing that's not constitutional
these [ __ ] delusional followers this
little bitty paired down [ __ ] just
absolute Jonestown type following that
they paired down to In This Nation
spread out through the 50 states and the
territories
is going to believe when the secretaries
of State say we have overturned this
election and we are giving it to Donald
Trump he may not even be on the ballot
who knows
they're going to believe them because
they believe just about bugging anything
these dumb [ __ ] tell them
and that's what makes it so dangerous
so as you're out there today having
conversations about
how Christopher Columbus is not a
founding father it's not a thing
you know it's gonna happen I'm telling
you I'm telling you now there are some
people that it they it's the
Italian-American Heritage thing but it
that's even weirder because he didn't
come here
he went to the Caribbean
he didn't even he didn't find America he
found the
West Indies
he was in the Caribbean and he was there
under the Spanish crown
so let's pluck our heads out of our
answers just a little bit and get to
reality folks I'm telling you this is
this is absolutely unbelievable you guys
love this shirt design
you love this shirt design the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty it is not Liberty it's in
the beginning of the show everyone this
and and we got coffee mugs now too with
the Liberty quote on it I said this uh
almost two years ago in a tick tock
and that's the reason why I'm sitting
here talking to you today is this quote
right here on this t-shirt the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty I'm not sure if the reason
why this is flying off the shelves is
because it's the only one of my uh
pieces of MRSA doesn't have a curse word
on it Aunt Tony he likes the word [ __ ]
but go pick up the your Liberty shirt
today at
store.dtonymichaels.com store dot the
Tony michaels.com you can look at all
our great merch we got Newton lock Em Up
merch we got Digger up
someone requested a digger up shirt so I
was like all right yeah fine I'll I'll
make a digger up shirt
I'll do that no problem and we've been
selling those too so don't forget to go
to
store.bdoneymichaels.com get your
Liberty shirt today it helps support the
podcast you are the best audience on
Earth on Earth you are the best audience
you guys have given us so much support
in the last several months with the
merch and and giving us a tip you can go
to Tony Michaels dot live slash tip you
can give us a one-time tip or you can
set it up monthly there at Tony Michaels
dot live
uh the best audience in the entire world
we are so lucky to have you here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch don't forget
to subscribe to the YouTube channel if
you're on here now and definitely don't
forget to go download every single
episode
on Apple Spotify Google it's there every
single weekday Monday through Friday
and don't forget to subscribe and give
us a great review on that directory
while you're there and if you're on
Facebook
if you're listening on Midas Touch
Facebook page come follow us on Facebook
at the Tony Michaels that page is
growing over there everyone everyone on
Facebook
on the books of face everyone has bad
stuff to say about Facebook but you know
what my experience so far with the show
in the last several weeks of just having
you guys follow me there and
broadcasting the show there on my page
because I broadcast the show on my
Facebook page
you guys have come over there and
commented and liked it you like my memes
over there
but so what happens is sometimes I make
them sometimes I find them and just the
ones that I like I I post over there on
the books of face
I have nothing but good things to say
about you folks on books if even you
fake Gabe great things I'm glad you show
up every single day and contribute to
the algorithm everyone stick around
we're gonna go through the shitless
Roundup boy do we have a lot of [ __ ] to
round up in the Tweety tweets and the
trendy Trends stick around don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] them Buckle [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
Monday Monday Monday Monday Monday
[Music]
you guys seen the uh the picture of
um Kerry Lake you know what Carrie lake
is
yeah this [ __ ] [ __ ] she is the
one who's running for governor of
Arizona and there's a big clip of her
talking about the border and talking
about children being trafficked and
Fentanyl just a bunch of [ __ ] lies
all right and I think it was yesterday
on Face the Nation I believe what it was
and just her just outright saying in
into a television just [ __ ] lies
straight lies
um and she wasn't challenged on it at
all
which is highly disappointing
and we we've we've went over this on
this show several times with Texas Paul
and I'm sure he'll bring this up
tomorrow when we have Texas Paul on on
Tuesday because tomorrow is Texas Paul
Tuesday taco Tuesday but it's Texas Paul
Tuesday as well here on the Tony
Michaels podcast
we've talked about this several [ __ ]
times
that the fentanyl is not coming across
the [ __ ] border
where they're walking in a cross
these thousands and thousands thousands
of pounds of of fentanyl are are coming
in vehicles
at the gate you know where you're
drawing through the gate on the highway
between Mexico and the United States and
they're seizing the majority of it
that's why so much is being is is being
bombarded because the majority of it's
being seized
they they are getting absolutely crazy
with this fentanyl talk
she literally [ __ ] said in this
interview and I I may play it I may not
I probably not I don't want to listen to
eight minutes of this slug
just absolutely [ __ ] puking up lies
on television and not being challenged
on it but that's one reason why we show
some of these clips to show you how to
[ __ ] in real time
destroy their lies she says that more
people in Arizona right now are dying
from fentanyl but then during the
pandemic
absolutely batshit Bonkers crazy stuff
just outright [ __ ] lies
I mean they're saying [ __ ] even on Fox
news about if you just look at fentanyl
you'll die
I'm not [ __ ] you they're getting to
that point
they're saying alls you have to do is
touch fitting on you're dead
that's what they're saying which is not
[ __ ] true and this is the stupid
Dangerous Drug talk from the same stupid
[ __ ] for decades and decades
like day like programs like dare who
have convinced people that marijuana is
the same as heroin it's not the same
it's not it's not it is not the same
it's not it's not the same [ __ ]
and you can't die if you just touch
Fentanyl
that's a [ __ ] lie it's a it's a lie
and Carrie lake is a [ __ ] delusional
Maga liar
she's delusional
she's lost
her mind the cheese has slid off the
cracker
when it comes to Kerry Lake
and there's no better there's no better
example of it than her trying to
vacuum a red carpet for her her orange
deity Donald Trump
and when you see the picture you're like
what in the [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is this
and I'm going to explain all of it I'm
going to explain all of it
why carry Lake was vacuuming
red carpet
that was placed on a big pile of sand
I'm going to explain why
that is a that's why they had to have
this uh Arizona rally where they had to
have it that's why she had to vacuum the
red carpet the sand out of it
for Grandpa poopy pants but she's a
[ __ ] liar
and how she was not challenged in this
interview is beyond me I have no clue
how this even happened
I'm not really [ __ ] sure
but it did it happened of course it did
so we might show that we got some other
stuff that we want to go through with
this rally you got Marjorie Taylor Green
Tommy tuberville Donald Trump himself
um confessing to crimes
confessing to crimes in front of
microphones
that's a thing that he keeps doing so
let's do this let's let's do this let's
go to the Tweety tweets and the trendy
Trends so we can round up the [ __ ] here
let's get to the [ __ ] list Roundup let's
start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Trends and the [ __ ] list Roundup
no boy
oh boy uh here is the um I think my yeah
my ghost has a
oh Gabe Sanchez tweeted it here
um
manga vacuums suck they both suck
so they're green now Kerry link
posted this
on her social media you see there's um
Carrie link there
vacuuming a red carpet and I'm gonna
show the picture of it that uh
um I forget who posted this picture of
her back you mean but she even posted
her a little video of her
hmm
vacuuming sand down to this red carpet
that's what she's doing she's vacuuming
the sand out of this red carpet that way
uh Donald Trump doesn't have any sand
um really weird oh it was Benny Johnson
that's who posted the picture nears Gabe
Sanchez's
uh
view of it
but uh let's go let's see let's see
oh yeah we're getting we got some Mike
Lindell footage
we got to my pillow guy footage for you
today too oh man the crazy did not stop
it didn't stop this weekend there's
plenty of crazy on on display here it is
here's Benny Johnson
and a little tweet I said worshiping a
golden Camp sounds very Christian to me
delusion uh here's Benny Benny Johnson's
stupid [ __ ] tweet of this picture
this is a real photo of Carrie Lake
vacuuming the red carpet before meeting
Donald Trump number one
when someone says red carpet don't you
think like a big piece of red carpet
that you know goes into like a uh I
don't know a [ __ ] building or
something
right
like you're being invited into a a
stadium or a hall or a
Auditorium
you know roll out the red carpet as they
say that's not what this is
um he goes on Benny Johnson goes on to
sycophant here and he says a member of
Kerry team
I don't know Carrie's team our team I'm
not sure he got that turned around told
us she insisted she insisted great
reporting here from Benny Johnson
groundbreaking [ __ ] she insisted on
personally making sure
the carpet was
spotless out of now this is in quotes
this is the quote he was given
by Kerry team
here's the quote
respect for the Office of the President
of the United States
oh Carrie he's not he's not the [ __ ]
president Jesus Christ I don't know how
many times we have to do this I don't
know how much election denying you have
to do what we have to do to explain it
to you he [ __ ] lost he's a [ __ ]
loser
now this next line was made up by Benny
Johnson himself and oh boy is this next
line to doozy
this this is what Benny Johnson said
this is the quote from the tweet for you
listening and not seeing this it says
this
is servant
leadership oh no it's it's [ __ ] gross
Gabe Sanchez this is [ __ ] gross is
what this is uh I mean like I said you
know there's a the Venn diagram of Maga
and vacuums is that they both [ __ ]
suck they both suck a lot it's and hard
too they suck oh yeah no I think they
got they got like the floor they got the
floor mode you know and then they got
the carpet mode you know and then I got
the other one that's like uh oh this
place is a total [ __ ] show mode where
they're like
you know right well I want to point
something out here and this is the
picture this is really strange to most
people who do not live in this region of
the country most people are like why why
did they have this in a sandbox now
for people who haven't been to Arizona
there's a lot of sand on the ground in
Arizona right
but you know it doesn't make sense why
they would bring sand into a building
game where a big Stadium where he would
have this huge rally right why would
they bring sand into a big huge Stadium
why don't they do that it's almost it's
almost like the uh
they're not at a stadium
Oh you mean you mean that they're that
most of the places in Arizona the big
Metropolis areas in Minnesota actually
Donald Trump owes them money so he can't
he can't hold events in big stadiums is
that what you're saying yeah also the
company that helped uh
helped
create or or uh plan those
uh going belly up really are you are you
saying that he bankrupt someone else or
that he you know that seems to be a
pattern with this guy yeah I mean like
pretty much anything that you know like
they say everything that Trump touches
dies and while it turns the liquid [ __ ]
is what I said yeah I think at this
point
um
he doesn't even need to touch it he just
like right just he just thinks it you
know just like the documents he just
thinks it and then that company goes
honestly it looks it I okay look I I
don't know if this is true but many
people are saying that Donald Trump held
his Arizona rally in a litter box I
don't know well maybe it was intentional
maybe it wasn't but for those of you
because I've only been to Arizona once
in my life I've only been there once
um and it was a great time we went
through Albuquerque New Mexico and it
was snowing believe it or not it was
kind of weird but it but we did that and
I've seen the Grand Canyon I looked over
it and it looked from the you know the
little rail it looked the same as it
does in the pictures but I was there in
real life I was there but here's here's
one here's the one I want to say the
reason why Donald Trump had to stand in
a bunch of in a [ __ ] cat litter box
here and a bunch of sand and why Carrie
lake is just
very
um handmade like vacuuming this carpet
because that really that's what it feels
like right like yeah the vacuuming is a
bad task right everyone should vacuum
but they actually made it a point and I
mean a team carry whatever their [ __ ]
campaign team is named uh Benny Johnson
said uh Carey team
to take a picture and take a video of
her doing this and post it on her social
media right this isn't this wasn't like
an act that was caught outside of their
campaign they literally wanted to have
these images and this imagery that she
is a sycophant and she is a cultist
of her vacuuming which again I don't
think it's a bad thing for Kerry Lake to
vacuum the carpet if she got there I was
like Jesus Christ who who let all the
sand on the [ __ ] carpet yeah who let
the sand out right turns out it was the
Nazis right
it's just a new song I don't know who
the student okay anyways
um
she gets there right I mean I I could
see it I get there some my guest is
gonna come there's sand all over this
this little
rug it's not even a carpet I mean it is
a carpet but it's a little well there's
a there's a rubber mat right and then
there's a red right like this is the
I have a few questions the main one is
did they buy this at a local shop like a
local local like
um
this is this is a this is a cut out this
is yeah so it's like do they have this
thing just all the time ready to go or
do you think that they just go buy a red
carpet cut out from like a sand like
they basically like hey we don't want to
buy the full thing can we get like a
sample and like sure like a sample is
like a two by two and like no well we
need something that's like eight by like
five and right that's a really big
sample well don't worry we'll come back
and we'll buy more right but they do it
every single time yeah probably that's
probably what happens because again if
if she got here and she's like there's a
bunch of sand on this carpet and she's
like look my guest is coming in I want
this to be clean and everyone's like
well [ __ ] you and she's like okay well
hand me the vacuum right yeah that is
not what happened here yeah that it's
not and and there was a picture taken of
her furiously vacuuming now a lot of
people pointed out
again Gary Lake
doesn't run a vacuum that often she just
she doesn't number one her cord her
um her chord strategy here is way off
yeah um I mean that court that court is
like is like crimped pretty right
well the other thing too if I if I do
this up see see her her technique here
she's got the cord in between her legs
and she's holding the cord which is a
normal technique with the other hand as
she's vacuuming but it looks like to me
that Carrie Lake doesn't vacuum that
often you wouldn't put the cord I mean
at least
and my my vacuuming experience of of
having the technique here I would not
put the cord in between my legs I
wouldn't do that
I think Gabe Sanchez just froze up on us
he got so scared of her
of her vacuuming strategy and her
technique here that he froze up he's
just completely Frozen but I wouldn't I
wouldn't actually vacuum like this I
don't know that anyone would
but you can see you can all right we
lost him all together he'll be back Gabe
Sanchez will be back don't worry it's
not the deep it might be the Deep State
I have no idea
maybe the Deep State's watching and
they're getting scared that um that we
that we're talking about Carrie
they don't know we're talking about
Carrie Lake I guess so I guess so they
were talking about these Nazis I don't
know what's going on somebody's [ __ ]
with my internet here
but the chord technique the chord
technique right you just vacuumed yet we
just you know my girlfriend vacuumed
yesterday and it's just whoa whoa whoa
hey you don't vacuum I vacuum
so what's your Technique when you vacuum
uh well depends on where the location of
the outlet is but typically I don't let
it hang on the ground because I want I
don't want to roll back over it so then
I'll let I'll let the slack go as I get
further down the hallway or into the
living room or something like that have
you ever fell down tripped over the
vacuum Gordon have you ever done that
because I'm not a [ __ ] idiot you know
why because you probably don't put it
between your legs
this is this is a recipe for disaster
here yeah when we're talking about
vacuuming listen
this this picture sucks all around it
really does suck because Carrie Lake
sucks at vacuuming and her vacuuming
sucks and she may I don't know she sucks
at other things too but this this
picture is um and really honestly it's
it's it's the tweet that Benny Johnson
put out with it right well let me go
back to the picture here for a second
because if you know I really thought I
was done making these rally what was
that videos but after I saw the clips
from yesterday there's getting worse
isn't it well it's getting I mean like I
you know I was like oh yeah these things
are getting more deranged and worse but
this one I feel like is more important
based on the the video clips of what
Trump says in this one oh yeah because
he's all over the map but you notice you
notice the uh the non-presidential seal
back here you notice this it says the
office of Donald J drum so he's got sand
in his office because that I just it's
weird I guess and it's a tent it's a
it's a tent well because remember they
can't be inside because he does doesn't
pay so someone's like and there was
actually I forget which rally he held
recently but there was a clip where he
was like oh yeah you know we held a
rally and no someplace I forget what
some area and he's like it was on a
field so we had 60 000 people as far as
the eye could see and it's like no you
had it there not because people could
just roll up but because you couldn't
actually pay the bill for these other
places it depends on where he goes and
who he's stumping for right whether
they'll allowed them to rent a stadium
the last rally I believe was in Ohio and
they allowed him to rent a um a venue in
Ohio in Arizona apparently he oh he owes
the City of Phoenix like the City of
Phoenix
like two three million dollars something
crazy yeah sounds crazy it is
I don't even know how this is still
possible like the fact that that not
that he's able to show up to these
states without pain but the fact that
he's able to to not pay these people
like nobody was like yeah we'll take a
down payment like typically if you're
gonna rent a venue like all right we
want half up front now in case you in
case you cancel because we could have
used that business for someone else
but then they don't show up or they
don't pay the funds right or or like the
service for a police force in the city
like all of these things that
as a president you know especially
doesn't do so you've got this moment now
where he's literally in this like sand
litter box
and they think oh hey look Kerry Lake
vacuuming and heels that's exactly what
we want out of our women these days
because we don't want them working which
is like then why are you running for
office carry Lake why are you even out
here
in addition to that I also look at this
and I'm like
when you take a photo okay first off
there's a bunch of sand all over so your
shoes are gonna get dirty no matter
where you Shuffle in or slide your foot
in like Trump does
in addition if you're standing on a red
little eight by five cut out piece of
red carpet
that's probably the best area you're
gonna be in where you won't get sand
even if there are specks of sand the
granularity of a piece of sand is so
small that you would not even see it or
notice it again you're in the best area
possible not actual Sandra on something
that has a little bit of sand on it and
when you take the photos in front of
that backdrop with those flags you're
not going to see the ground you're not
going to see the ground because they
have the lights there that are shining
on the flags this whole [ __ ] thing is
so performative and so staged it doesn't
[ __ ] make sense so I did not plan
this out I promise I made this because
when we go to a really shitty tweet I
always tweet here on the show your Tweet
sucks
it does featured on the Tony Michaels
podcast and this one finally finally I
can literally literally literally is
tweet it sucks so let's see yeah now
when it sucks that's great that's great
um I do want to go through some more
important Clips um yeah because the the
cultishness of that
um her vacuum the carpet because it
really is culty
right yeah it's just weird it is it is
so strange like did she run the vacuum
on the rest of the sand
she's like I'm gonna clean this place up
it is Dusty like a mother
well
outside the cultishness there was a lot
of [ __ ] racism and hatred oh sweet
yeah oh my God they rolled it out baby
oh they were they were playing in that
sandbox oh hells to the yeah here's uh
here's Marjorie hoof foot green
um divorce divorce say green yeah she's
on the stage is she officially are they
officially divorced well I know I mean
it'll take a while I'm curious to see
because they got to split up their money
yeah right well because yeah that's a
good point because
um uh Marjorie Taylor Green's husband
actually uh when he filed in Georgia
right he kept it under seal
and then she [ __ ] around and then he
was like okay well then we'll unseal it
then yeah if you're gonna if you're
gonna do because she's like we want
privacy and then he's like no we don't
want privacy I'm gonna show the whole
world who you are so um which you know
it's too bad the guy had to be married
to her for 27 years I don't know how he
lasts that long to be quite honest with
you after you hear this clip I have to
hear this clip
you're gonna understand what I'm talking
about because she talks about a certain
type of replacement here not it's it's
it's a certain type of replacement let's
let's listen
Joe Biden's 5 million illegal aliens are
on the verge of replacing you
Joe Biden's 5 million illegal aliens are
they do when they jump across the border
or come across the border gate do they
give them Biden tattoos or something
they all get they all get stamped or
something I guess according to the
Republicans well of course it's going to
be weird I mean like this is this is
them this is the Republican Party
projecting their own
because what the Republican it's their
own like fears right and so where the
Republican Party creates this Boogeyman
right and says his Boogeyman whatever it
might be it could be fentanyl that was
seized at the border it could be uh
migrants who are seeking Asylum it could
be gasoline prices that are not dictated
by Biden but Biden does things to help
uh release the pressure on everyday
consumers it could be you know all these
other things that they want to complain
about
and they project those problems they
create these imaginary problems and then
they [ __ ] and moan about them and then
they obviously don't solve them but this
is another one of those things where
they're like oh when these five million
illegals come okay first off where are
you getting 5 million from
are you are you counting them are you
are you doing the accounting on this I
doubt you can count higher than nine
like when she gets to ten she's she's
already struggling on the on the on the
five fingers on each hand I mean we know
she can't count on her toes because
she's got three or four on each one
but is it three or is it four well I I
think we confirmed that when she was
simping over that one that one
insurrectionist guy in the jail cell at
the CPAC right she had four at least on
one foot we saw four on one foot we
don't right okay so there's at least
four at least four okay good but it it's
just this projection of like we got this
problem these five million where are you
getting five million from how are you
doing five million people how are they I
just I'm confused I mean I know what
she's saying here I know what she's
saying here well it's a great
replacement Theory it's the [ __ ] it's
white replacement is what she's saying
and she's saying brown people are
Democrats is what she's saying besides
you know one's like Herschel Walker
Candice Owens and Kanye West right and
those guys that stand behind them that
says uh blacks for Trump right those
well those aren't really people of color
because they're against wife's right
replacement so they're really anyways
she's saying white replacement here is
what she's saying this is the [ __ ] that
Fox News and Tucker Carlson has been has
been pushing for the last two damn years
right
um this idea that immigrants are going
to replace you and and she pairs it
along with an interview before and I
might show that too where she's talking
about Democrats killing Republicans
because that's what they want you to
believe well not us they want these
delusional white folks In This Crowd to
believe that Democrats are going to kill
you to replace you with a brown person
now brown people are coming here that is
the thing that they are doing that
migrants are coming here most of them
seeking Asylum which is legal uh fake
Gabe in the in the chat it's legal to
seek Asylum I don't know if you know
laws maybe you should do your own
research uh I'm gonna bring up a a
little comedy out here here in a second
about that but um she talks about how in
this other clip how Democrats are
killing Republicans and this is because
when you talk about replacement I mean
what what other thing could you be
saying besides killing someone what do
they mean by replacing like they're
gonna take your home and kick you out
and then you're gonna be homeless or
where where where do these people live
that this is that they think this is the
same I think in the same clip she talks
about taking jobs and again I've said
this before and and you've also said
this right like when you look at
Hispanic people especially Mexicans you
know like my family
some of the hardest [ __ ] working
people that I know right the the the
amount of
uh kind of
importance of Labor and and work ethic
is built deep inside the culture yeah
and proving that you are worthy of being
here in the United States like that is
something that my dad
ingrained on me oh the guy is still
working to this day like he cannot break
from one for his his love for what he
does but also too
because I don't know if the guy can stop
and it's what do you mean like like it's
it's almost like a mental thing where he
his brain his brain is telling him to
work because that's all his brain knows
how to yeah I mean like I know like
he'll you know he'll take vacation and
time off but at the same time I feel
like there's something that's like just
ingrained in him that he had to prove
himself as a non-white person in this
country that it's like I have to work I
have to show that I approve and I I
contribute and I have value in this
country and it's one of those things
that I think that is in that is also
true for other people who have parents
of color who are trying to prove
themselves especially someone who isn't
born in this country right and so when I
hear something like she says oh they're
coming to replace you they're going to
steal your jobs [ __ ] because if that
were true then you would see a bunch of
white people picking lettuce and
strawberries in a field you would see
these people in a in a poultry uh a
factory you would see them working uh
you know main processing meat processing
or or Hospitality or clean or whatever
it might be if that were actually true
you would see these people saying whoa
whoa whoa I'm trying to apply for this
job and I can't get this job for XYZ but
really what it is is these people
creating a problem saying that these
people shouldn't have these jobs AKA
non-white people shouldn't have these
jobs but the reality of is white people
aren't looking for these jobs because
they're lazy no offense but that's what
it really is I have I have a I have a
friend
um who owns a roofing business so what
he does and he's done it for years and
years and years he owns a roofing
business and he's always told me he's
he's he said this he said when I when I
have a crew of Mexican fellas come and
do a job usually the oldest dude
within that crew is that is that the
head guy right he's the he's the foreman
of the crew right and he's like that
that guy probably came here
when he was broke and had no money and
was sending every single nickel back to
his family
in Mexico he said and that guy will not
let those young guys [ __ ] stop they
don't get to take break I mean the only
time those young guys get to take breaks
is when he's taking a break right that's
it it won't let them stop he said he
will not he hates having white Crews
because he said the white Crews get
about a a quarter done
what the Mexican Crews do and the reason
why is because they have work ethic deep
embedded into their culture yeah and
rather it's what you're saying which I I
believe that's the truth is because I
I've met these Crews I've seen these
crews in my experience in construction
is that literally they feel like they
have something to prove yeah they have
something to prove they have to earn to
earn to be here in this country whereas
these people in this crowd they didn't
earn [ __ ] [ __ ] especially the one at
the microphone didn't earn [ __ ]
and that's that's the the cold-blooded
truth here's uh here's this comment by
fake grape he says in certain States
illegals can vote in local elections
that's not true you dummy you're such a
[ __ ] idiot I wish illegals could vote
in their local elections they live there
they they contribute to the community
most of the time most of the time the
illegals are probably contributing more
to the community as far as labor than
what the than what the legal residents
are but illegals can't vote in local
elections what you're talking and send
me a link play the whole clip fake game
listen what you're talking about is
there certain municipalities in this
country that realize that there are
legal residents in their in their
community that cannot vote but they
actually have a stake in those votes
like local local sales tax
um if they're building a local park if
they're if they're gonna do Municipal
work like sewers
um cable sidewalks streets you are a
dumb [ __ ] man you just come here
every day and don't disappoint I mean
you absolutely give me the Trump copy
machine Fed Up on a platter here yep so
go do your own research fake game and
figure out that what you're talking
about is not what you're saying and also
to show fake and anyone else who wants
to be a [ __ ] bigot uh
you've got Florida
and you've got fascist Ron DeSantis
right
and he says hey you know what I'm gonna
own the lipstick I'm gonna send all
these all these migrants who are seeking
Asylum from Venezuela up to Martha's
Vineyard and I'm gonna show them who's
[ __ ] boss because I run this [ __ ]
right
well guess who
is the first group that is willing to
help fix and repair and rebuild the
State of Florida after Hurricane Ian
ravaged through that state I only need
one guess I only need one all right I
would imagine I would imagine that it's
migrants yeah yeah ding ding ding winner
winner chicken dinner turns out the
people that Ron DeSantis hates the most
are still
[ __ ] willing to come over and say we
will help you we will help you rebuild
this community because that's who we are
you know it is it is unfortunate that
you as a person are so vile and
god-awful that you are willing to use
people as political pawns and mislead
them from Texas put them on a plane and
ship them out over uh to Martha's
Vineyard but you know what
we will come back we will come here we
will help you we will we will contribute
to the community
and it's amazing it's amazing because
you know what honestly it's very hard
for me to imagine any other group or
just a group of people if you were if
you were completely
shunned off to the side right they just
like the Hispanic Community to be like
you're you're illegal you don't deserve
to be here get out of here
the fact that those are the first people
willing to say you know what
look you got some real problems that you
have going on personally but we won't
hold it against everyone else in the
state so we're going to help out
the fact that those people are so
willing to help out is amazing and
honestly they're a better person than I
would be because if someone [ __ ]
shaded my
my people like my Hispanic Community I
probably would not
want to do that I probably would not be
the first one in line to be like hey I'm
gonna help out
because I might take it personally and I
probably would take it personally for
the things that
you know Trump and DeSantis and all
these other Republican people have done
against the the Hispanic community so
again it's it's the first the first
group that is willing to come down and
repair the damage that was done by
Hurricane Ian is the same group of
people
same community that Ron DeSantis and his
fascist regime are willing to play
political pawns with
fake Gabe says he owned us and so as you
say he said owned what he doesn't know
is he got a cell phone here he got a
cell phone see what what he was saying
in the comments is that illegals vote
because this is this is what she's gonna
say I'm gonna show you that his little
his little
um Soldier here Marjorie Taylor green
Gabe's little
um you know queen bride here
is gonna say that they're gonna
illegally vote they're gonna replace you
in your vote and blah blah blah yakety
smackity bunch of racist [ __ ] but what
he doesn't know is when he did the
comment that I brought up and I knew he
was going to do this
he was gonna bring up the fact and here
he brings it up the New York City's
non-citizen voting law is struck down by
the state supreme court justice from
Staten Island says the measurer would
have allowed more than 800 000
non-citizens to vote violation of the
State Constitution fake Gabe then that
means you got on you dummy so it is
either one or the other either your
dumbass believes that that non-citizens
illegals are voting are you believe that
they are not one or the other you stupid
[ __ ] okay can you can you pull that
comment back up
all right so a non-citizen voting law is
struck down
again
I ask you to prove it to me and you
proved your point what I was trying to
tell you I said municipalities are
trying to make it to where non-citizens
can vote on local municipal
measures and you said oh illegals are
voting they're illegals are voting and
then you say then you provide the proof
saying I got owned by owning yourself
showing the evidence of why illegals
aren't allowed to vote you [ __ ] fool
again fake game take take just a moment
and pluck
your head all the way out pluck I know
it's really jammed up it's far it's far
D it's it is deep in that Maga vacuum to
to sniff that big back but pluck your
head out of your ass and understand what
I am telling you and listen to every
word that I say and then maybe you won't
get owned he says owned I think he maybe
he was talking about himself I thought
he said about us I think I think he goes
oops I got owned he forgot to include
the first part he goes my bad I got
owned I got owned and this is crazy okay
let's let's continue with the racist
here Marjorie who foot green replacing
your jobs and replacing your kids in
school and coming from all over the
world they're also replacing your
culture and that's not great for America
replacing your kids in school what does
that even mean does that mean like
schools are like oh white white children
have to stay at home I I've never heard
of this
I haven't heard what the [ __ ] are they
talking about I don't know maybe maybe
this is kind of crazy but I wouldn't I
wouldn't doubt it in terms of what she
believes maybe Marjorie Taylor greens
that this is like the plot from like uh
you know like uh Body Snatchers right
you know like Invasion of the Body
Snatchers where she thinks you've never
heard you've never seen a movie it's an
older movie but anyway basically like uh
she I think she thinks
that migrants are coming in and then are
going to copy themselves to what white
people look like and replace them and
then they're going to kill off the
original right so they're the copy they
kill the original person so they think
like a bunch of Migrant kids are coming
in and they're gonna be like oh boom
boom body snatched like that's that's
some cue level conspiracy and I would
not doubt it if she actually believes
that because she is really that
unintelligent and again dumb people vote
for dumb people so in November please
vote for Marcus flowers and unseat right
dumb [ __ ] this person who thinks
that
wind turbines
which I hope you have that clip for
later
oh well you can pull it up yes yeah
Patriot takes basically shared this clip
of Margaret Taylor green talking about
wind turbines and energy and the things
I don't wanna I don't want to ruin what
she says so I'm going okay don't ruin it
I haven't actually seen this clip so but
I want to go I want to go see if you can
find that club because I got another
Margaret Taylor green I want to show
um but here is another racist standing
on stage
honestly I wish they would just say the
word okay
um
today is today is indigenous people day
and a lot of people get um history
confused turned around and I talked
about this in the first 30 minutes
Tommy tuberville
doesn't even get he doesn't even know
our own government's the system of
government that we had he gets it turned
around but when he comes
from Alabama
to bring the pause the pause you had
that really made me think you're going
somewhere else with this but all right
where where did you think I was well you
just stopped after it comes so
oh when he comes
from Alabama and brings his
um traditional white Southern racism
and I believe this is in Nevada because
they had two of them this weekend right
they went to Nevada and then they went I
mean they got to Double Down they've got
little time right little little time
left because they're you know they're
they're stumping for commercial Walker
tomorrow it's they go oh really okay
yeah so Scott God damn so so here is
here is Tommy tuberville and I grew up
in white Rural America game yeah
and
the n-word was thrown around like crazy
it was part of the culture
there weren't many black folks in our
town there just weren't
and that's probably one of the reasons
why
now Tommy tuberville here in this clip
now remember this is a guy who was a
coach of Auburn okay Auburn is not a
small School in Alabama yeah not only
that is it is a very big football
program and he's the coach
now he reveals in this clip how he feels
about all those black athletes that he
was in charge of while he was the coach
of Auburn and it's actually kind of sad
to me
but my sadness comes from that Tommy
tuberville just won't say the word I
wish because they say the quiet part out
loud so much and there and they have
their megaphone on so much
and I I know Tommy tuberville uses that
word on a daily basis and if this clue
does not prove it to you you are not
coupled to reality whatsoever
but I wish I just wish that Tommy
duberville would show his real true
colors here and say the word that he
wants to use he would I wish he would
use his freedom of speech to say what he
wants to say here
but he won't and the main reason why he
won't is because there's huge
consequences for him to say that word
but there needs to be even bigger
consequences for him not saying that
word and what I mean by that is he is he
is alluding to a certain word and you're
going to know what that [ __ ] word is
you probably already know what I'm
talking about
but we need to punish the Republican
party for having this dumb [ __ ]
on stage and letting him say the [ __ ]
that he's about that you're about to
hear that he said into a microphone in
Nevada while stumping
for candidates
before Donald Trump even come on he said
this [ __ ] let's listen they said some
people say Well they're soft on crime no
they're not soft on crime they're
pro-crime they won't crime they won't
cry because they want to take over what
you got they want to control what you
have they want reparation because they
think the people that do the crime are
owed that [ __ ]
they think the people who do the crime
are owed reparations who could he
possibly talking about Gabe a guy from
Alabama a guy from Alabama who could he
possibly be maybe we should maybe we
should float this question a fake game
maybe fake game would I bet he knows who
is they yeah who is he talking about
they that want reparations the criminals
he basically just called all black
people criminals is what I heard that's
what I heard now in the first part of
the clip he's saying they want
reparations for them
it makes me feel like he's saying he's
saying and and we we talked about um the
very first episode of the Dave Chappelle
Show
um last week when we watched Herschel
Walker
um we talked about uh Herschel Walker we
talked about Kanye West we talked about
Candace Owens
um and the Clayton Bixby episode of the
Dave Chappelle show it makes me feel
like
he wants to say the n-word here oh yeah
yeah it is
[ __ ] he's such a [ __ ] why wouldn't
he just say it
I'm sick of these people alluding to it
I'm sick of them talking the code word
the code talk [ __ ] that's all this is is
it's inward code talk for these these
[ __ ] white people sitting in this
crowd for a a group of people who hate
pronouns they sure know how to use they
and them real well they do they love
they and them yeah they [ __ ] like
they did it
they are the they are the ones who are
committing crime they are the ones who
want to do this
is it is it really because you guys have
this secret fascination of obsession
that you want them to do the crime so
that you can then punish them in any way
that you want like like you have this
it's almost like they're like look
commit the crime commit the crime I
won't do anything okay [ __ ] put your
hands up like that's they want to like
entrap them in this moment like commit
the like anyone who is not white to be
commit the crime and then I've got my
guns ready whenever you [ __ ] commit
to crime and there you go here you go
here you go here's fake Gabe you got it
he got it but you you missed it you
missed it figured I asked I ask I ask
you just be specific tell me and tell me
in one word tell me in one word Gabe one
word who you're talking about here who
is they who is this community
the community the see you then like
print okay doesn't like pronouns he
won't use that the community I would
love to hear which group which
demographic describe it to me what is
the color of their skin say it right out
loud right oh no I want him to use the
word that fake a wants to use yeah I
mean he'll get blocked because you
really shouldn't use that word in the
Facebook Chat I'm sure the mod's over
there oh okay there it is there it is
that's three words wow that's three
words but you know you're close you're
close wow look at that yeah look at that
oh is that who he's talking about is
that who he's talking about that's that
who he's talking about fake Gabe how
would you know that's who he's talking
about how would you know the Tommy
tuberville is saying that the people who
commit crimes are the people who want
reparations how would you know that fake
Gabe it's almost like Tommy tuberville
is talking in code to your dumb ass
um
they gave never [ __ ] fails does he no
he is just the Trump always machine man
always God damn they gave
um someone says it here Linda says it
here you are a racist
God damn hmm God damn
well I mean everyone knew this yeah but
I mean at least we got fake Gabe to
admit something that was true today
right thank you vape Gabe yeah for now
revealing yourself in the chat now you
now you're on a Road to Redemption
here um
so that we know truly who you are oh my
God they're they're all over him on
Facebook oh yeah now Facebook Facebook
is not a fan of you over there Vicky oh
[ __ ]
oh no not Gabe Dublin down these are
facts oh boy
wow ah good good good lucks good luck
with your alternative facts there fake
oh man okay so I'm speaking of racist um
let's listen to what um Marjorie did you
said she's going to talk about wind
turbines
yep oh this has got to be good this is
22 seconds long so it's not long so we
don't have to listen to her too long
here but let's listen he stopped
propping up American Oil and Gas
and gas wind turbines are the way to go
I mean what's he gonna do when it's not
a windy day he's gonna stand out there
and blow hot air and all the wind
turbines
because that's basically what he does
he's not going to deliver the energy
that we need and solar's not there yet
either
very frustrating
okay so apparently she
does she she's that the only way that
energy is converted is the day of the
moment that it happens basically it's
not like oh energy is then stored on an
energy Grid or like wow I mean I've said
this before in tweets she definitely
does not understand how batteries work
nope I mean it's it's really funny
because let me let me go back to it just
I'm not going to play this again but you
see the microphone she's holding uh it
doesn't have a cord on it it's cordless
do you know what that means that's
inside this microphone to some extent
whoa whoa no there is a energy source
it's no the hell is that thing called
it's it's brand new technology really
it's I mean it's like it is brand new
stuff this is ground breaking technology
is it
is it a
oh God I'm Sophie I'm so afraid I'm
gonna get this wrong is it battery it's
a battery oh battery thank goodness you
win thank you I can't understand how
these morons don't understand there is
such thing a technology called batteries
and they've been around for a long time
this idea that solar is new is really
[ __ ] stupid this is really [ __ ]
stupid they've been there have been
people perfecting storing solar energy
and batteries yeah since the 1930s and
40s
it really is it really is baffling that
people don't understand the reason why
solar isn't The prominent source of
energy in this country is because fossil
fuel companies made sure to box out
renewable energy right made sure that I
mean we know what happened you know when
the first electric cars were introduced
in the 70s and they were wait whoa whoa
whoa hey watch your mouth watch your
mouth Elon Musk invented the electric
car there were no electric cars in the
1970s I'm just saying and then what
happened I think it was under Twitter he
didn't oh he just invented Twitter right
he invented it he invented it it was his
idea I think it was I can't remember the
and who bought it who which city car was
oh 60s actually too but uh oil crisis
1970s uh oh what happened it spurred in
a sudden interest in electric vehicles
so there was actually a company called
City Car
um and they set up a company called
Sebring Vanguard to build it and then it
was produced from 1974 to 1977. it was
actually in Florida of all states
hmm uh but yeah the oil and gas industry
obviously doesn't like the fact that
there was competition or the possibility
that someone would be able to drive
something that was an alternative to the
thing that they wanted high prices for
it almost happened
oh yeah exactly so here's the thing
you've got these
advancements in technology that are made
that are that are Advanced every single
year right that is technology that's how
technology works right you invent
something you create it they say Hey how
do I make it more efficient how can I
store more energy How can I convert more
energy when it comes to these
alternatives to fossil fuels
solar wind
Hydro like there's many sources of
energy that can be converted or many
sources of of natural natural power that
can be converted into energy right
and I believe Marjorie Taylor green
thinks she thinks
that you can only run something in that
moment like oh I can only get energy
from these wind turbines if it's on a
windy day like where does the energy go
for all the other windy days you know
the other thing about these wind
turbines and non-windy days they
generally and and just generally
speaking when you would invest and I do
mean invest because private companies
are are buying these wind farms because
there's money in selling electricity
it's a thing that happens in this
country
They Don't Really build a wind farm in a
spot
where there's not a lot of wind like
they specifically seek out places
where there's a hell a lot of wind that
way they can make sure to maximize the
wind turbines turning and that's the
other craziest part to me is because
they talk about oil solar panels they
only they only gather energy when when
the sun is going oh okay and when
turbines only when the wind is blowing
well
in some places in the country depending
on how high the wind turbine is it's
almost 24 hours a day that the wind is
going that there's just like the sun is
out for most of the day I mean my
building has solar panels on it to heat
the water in our building yeah are they
are they are did George Soros come and
install them himself he did he dropped
down from this like supersonic Super PAC
private jet okay dropped down and it was
like clink clink clink clink clink any
like screwed them in and connected the
pipes it was crazy it was crazy
it was like using this technology I've
never seen before but actually Gary B
brings up something really interesting
here that I totally want to people to
remember is that Jimmy Carter did in
fact put solar panels on the roof which
by the way
it's not hurting anyone nobody who wait
a second Jimmy Carter was the president
in what decade that had to have been
just three years ago because yeah it was
it was brand new it was pretty recent
you know it's he's the the peanut farmer
who came into office and was like hey
why don't we put some solar panels on
the roof because it's not really hurting
anyone and every view that you see of
the White House is from just the front
or the back or the side no one's ever
looking on the on the top but Jimmy
Carter was like Hey solar panels that's
something we should invest in right and
it'll get better and better as time goes
on and then Ronald Reagan came in and
said [ __ ] that liberal [ __ ] that's
getting out of here get those [ __ ]
panels out of here and then Obama in I
think 2014 was like yeah we should
probably put these things in again
because this [ __ ] you know in his second
term he was like [ __ ] it No One's Gonna
[ __ ] come after me now I got a tan
suit controversy that already passed me
and I got the solar panels the mustard
right muster gate was a big one I mean
better than ketchup gate well true true
well speaking of delusional ideas that
this weirdo has she thinks if she thinks
Democrats are killing Republicans let's
listen to this this is before
the rally I'm not sure which uh which
Nazi rally this was before but I think
it's the one in Nevada but let's listen
there like Hillary Clinton declared us
all deplorable and ever since that day
the media and the Democrats and those in
charge
that not only means how they feel about
our views and opinions and our speech it
also means we're alive Democrats are
killing Republicans it's the most
dangerous thing in this country
so because Hillary Clinton said the word
deplorable that means Democrats are now
I mean she actually said it was a basket
of deplorables right isn't that what she
said yeah something like that but I mean
but I mean and that deplorables are
second-class citizens that's an
interesting view too yeah that they're
second-class citizens it almost it's
almost like my phrase the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty like absolutely is something
that these people do not understand that
your your
view of equality is not oppression and
that's usually what happens with the
oppressor is the oppressor sees equality
as oppression yeah because you're like
whoa whoa you're gonna give those people
rights how dare you and here's the other
fear that she's that she's stoking here
and and
um deplorable I'll say it deplorable
white Trump supporters believe this
through and through it probably back me
up here they believe this that if I am
equal
with people of color
then that means Society will treat me
the way that I want to treat them
do you follow me on that so their
thought is their fear is is that if if I
have a quality with people of color
then Society will treat me like I want
to treat people of color wait wait wait
wait wait are you are you telling me
that that this kind of mentality this
this belief in you should treat others
how you want to be treated it's almost
like it's uh it's called the Golden Rule
it's uh you know based on something I
don't know like the Bible that says hey
we should be nice to our neighbor we
should respect them and we should love
them easy Christianity and white
Christian nationalism is two different
things I'm just saying I'm just saying
they call it the Golden Rule it's like
shining it's a beacon of light it's how
you should treat someone
needs in the chat they must they must
have been ah there he is um
areas there he is there he is backing up
backing up the racism there good job the
FBI that yeah
that's what because that's what he's
saying he fake game is terrified is
terrified if equality comes to fruition
in this country that the FBI will treat
him just like they that's like he wants
law enforcement to treat people of
Geller that's right if they gave us
terrified of that that he'd may just be
treated like a black person
he may be treated like a black person
and he doesn't like that because he
wants to treat them in a certain manner
it's
um
hey Gabe you just you're wearing it all
over today okay just a quick I'm seeing
some breaking news that uh Caitlyn
brings in Cassidy Hutchinson and I've
just I've just confirmed this oh do we
have an article or something that we can
show yeah yeah good put that up and
we'll we'll get in on there
so it looks like Cassidy Hutchinson is
cooperating with Fannie Willis now
Fannie Willis remind me again which
criminal investigation this is because
there's so many yeah you're losing count
no I get it I get it it's the one that
is in Georgia oh again another a
different state different investigation
is this is this the one is this the one
um
that is involves illegal elections even
though vague games like oh the illegals
are voting voting but uh is this the one
where the gang was asking he he declares
it a perfect phone call but is this the
one where dude is asking and the
Secretary of State to just just find 12
000 votes it's like 11 846 but yeah just
find me twelve thousand votes the exact
number I need to win is that the one is
that that's the one he's like look I
just need this many because this is what
I need to win
uh and
maybe we should let the FBI know that
maybe we should let the F oh maybe
someone already has oh
yeah I've got this I think this is the
article are you reading this from CNN
let's see if you can confirm it I've got
one article that talks about yeah yeah
that's right I got it
okay send over that article here uh your
ears fake Gabe again when the government
fears the people there is Liberty when
the people fear the government there is
tyranny the people are the government
okay got it listen to me get your ear
turn up the volume hey Gabe say it
slower people
are the government the government the
government that Thomas Jefferson
Anderson was talking about here
was a monarchy you stupid [ __ ] wait wait
wait this is this is not a quote from
two years ago
no Thomas Jefferson said this
a long time ago oh okay a long time ago
so Thomas Jefferson wasn't around a
couple years ago is that what you're
saying he's not the guys the guy's like
super dead
it's sort of oh he's been taking a dirt
nap for some time oh gotcha gotcha okay
so he's not been around so a lot of
things have changed over the uh how many
ever years hundreds of years it could be
a couple could be a couple so a lot has
changed I mean a few things yeah but he
definitely he definitely was around for
electric cars right well most definitely
and he definitely is the Godfather of of
um wind turbines as well
um yeah and he knows how batteries work
um here is the headline first on CNN
breaking news
former White House State cooperating we
got the undies commercial up there I
must be looking at undies on the
internet that's they're feeding me on
these ads hey Alicia's not porn heads
you know I'm not looking at porn you
know that is I need some new [ __ ]
underwear no to be honest to be honest
with you the reason why the undies
commercial is up here is because Gabe's
like hey we should try to get them as a
sponsor what do you guys think yeah I
think we should get the men's underwear
you think big Gabe would buy my me
undies it might that might they doesn't
like pronouns any but he might like the
Kat undies um here we go the headline is
first on CNN former White House aide
cooperating with investigation of trump
effort to overturn election results
ooh this doesn't sound good
for Trump and CNN goes on to say at
Atlanta area prosecutor investigating
Donald Trump and his allies efforts to
overturn the 2020 election
has secured cooperation from former
Trump White House aide Cassie Hutchison
sources familiar with the matter to tell
CNN I believe now I'm not going to go on
read every single bit of this article
you guys can go look up the article and
read it I believe the reason why this is
so significant is the reason why her
testimony from the January 6th select
committee was so significant because it
everyone remembers Cassidy Hutchinson
wasn't only a member of the White House
staff where she was on the staff of Mark
Meadows she became part of the
Mar-A-Lago office of drunk staff after
he lost big time bigly and he had to go
down to Mar-A-Lago tuck his tail take
his 35 stolen boxes of documents down to
Mar-A-Lago she went with him
right I think that's why there's
significance here yeah
I mean also just because of her
connection I mean she's one degree
separated right you know between Mark
Meadows and so
she would have been within steps of the
conversation right especially as these
you know this assistant too right and
Hall her position was not only for Mark
Meadows but then transition into that of
the president so it's something that
it's like yeah of course she would be
someone of interest because she's been
privy to certain things she's heard
certain conversations probably been in
communication via email or text message
with someone that might have said
something so to include her in this
investigation but also for her to say
yeah I'm cooperating with this is I
think a big move to prove again that
Trump was not only making this perfect
phone call you know in requesting the 11
700 and he say that [ __ ] on the stage
yeah he's like like uh there was which I
forget which rally I did or what was
that on but it was um
I forget it was a few rallies ago but he
was like you'd be proud of me it was a
perfect phone call and it's like well he
did that shame stick a couple times this
weekend because he does the same shtick
he just gets a little more fascist each
time he says it speaking of January 6th
um there is a new uh audio
of Officer fanone he was one of the
officers on the ground during January 6
that was beaten to almost to an inch of
his life
um and Brian sicknick's mom there's
audio of them meeting with Kevin
McCarthy ooh
um and it was released this morning by
CBS and Scott the friend of the show
Scott McFarland
um
it's not good for Kevin McCarthy is this
the meeting
where they uh
where they caught him after the
interview
in in Capitol Hill
I believe so
um
like a little [ __ ] or whatever yeah
let's listen to the tape and we can we
can um here we have first access this
morning to audio secretly recorded by
one of the police officers injured in
the assault on the capitol now this
comes after a meeting with Republican
lawmakers after the attack and it's
being released ahead of what could be
the January 6 committee's last public
hearing which is scheduled for Thursday
the officer in question says what
happened in that meeting only added to a
suffering Scott McFarland has more
foreign
hailed as a hero on January 6th officer
Michael Fanon was beaten tased and
wounded trying to stop the rioters
now in connection to a new book by Fanon
CBS News has been given the first access
to a surreptitious audio recording he
made during a June 2021 meeting between
officers who responded January 6th and
housed Republican leader Kevin McCarthy
who spoke about his actions at the
Capitol that day so I was trying to
convey to everybody I was about inspired
you what is happening inside
and that's when I went on television too
the mother of Officer Brian sicknick who
died of natural causes a day after the
attack was also in the meeting and asked
McCarthy why then president Trump didn't
call off the mob do you know what was
going on you know they were fighting for
hours and hours and hours
you know we just
[Music]
moment
in another exchange the known challenges
McCarthy when the Republican leader
urges against politicizing January 6th
now this is very important because I
want to talk about this part of the clip
beforehand
um because finone is just a police
officer
he's not he's he's not
um his job is not to enter into politics
his job is not to engage in biotics his
job is to be a police officer and to
protect and serve
now there's a lot of there's a lot of
back and forth in this country Over law
enforcement and I think there should be
we should have a lot of conversation
about what law enforcement is in law
enforcement reform
but the one thing that Michael Fanon
does here
to Kevin McCarthy when he absolutely
unwinds this ridiculous argument that
this [ __ ] was not political
um because that that is what Republicans
continue to do here and to this day this
narrative that he's about this lie that
he's about to spew in front of these
families
who lost their loved ones and were
almost lost themselves just doing their
job the lie that he's about to spread
is [ __ ] ridiculous and I've said this
time and time again we need to
politicize every single point because
it's politics folks and really honestly
the January 6th which we're going to
have a hearing this week on Thursday it
may be the last one that we have but
we're going to broadcast it here live
um in conjunction with the Midas touch
Network
as we've done all the ones in the past
and we're gonna find out what's going to
happen in that hearing but Michael
vannone here not being in politics not
involved in the politics absolutely 100
percent wants Kevin McCarthy's argument
that this this isn't shouldn't be isn't
political he winds it up and dunks and
in the trash here and I think this is
why I wanted to play this clip
this morning is because of this this
right here what Fanon does to McCarthy
let's listen
I mean unfortunately
Kevin I agree with you the problem is it
is political because it happened here on
Capitol Hill and it involved a political
movement it involved a group of
extremist white white
um
right wing uh element of our you know
American society which was mobilized by
politicians and that's just a fact in a
separate meeting with Republican senator
Lindsey Graham Fanon described the
assault officers faced
so there is the uh the portion of the
clip about
um yes it is politics it was politics
they came there because of politics it
was politicians directing them it was
politicians who gave them the
opportunity by stalling the
certification which was not not a thing
that was going to happen it wasn't going
to change the outcome stalling it by
giving them the the opportunity to come
and violently storm the capital not only
that a politician who wanted to go to
the Capitol and directed them to go
there to do this
it is 100 all of it January 6 the lead
up the actual events on that day and the
lies afterwards are all politics and
tell our country comes to know the fact
that Fanon knows that it's all politics
and we should we should politicize every
single bit of it because folks if we do
not we will lose in politics and if we
lose in politics we will lose our
democracy that is the most important
thing from this clip I actually believe
that this is one of the most brilliant
clips that we've seen released
apparently this audio clip is um part of
a book that he's going to release
um but this audio clip should have been
done months ago again you know our
feelings on books and yeah
facts and this sort of thing but this is
one of the most brilliant clips
this is one of the most brilliant Clips
um coming out of this to show that Kevin
McCarthy even in front of the families
who lost loved ones
tries to tries to make sure that those
people don't engage in this politically
mm-hmm is what he's trying to do let's
finish up the clip and then and then
we'll talk about it on the other side
benon writes Graham responded you guys
should have shot them all in the head we
have much work yet to do finone's
Revelations come as the house January 6
select committee prepares to return to
the spotlight this week following a
summer of behind the scenes
investigating and seeking more records
from the U.S Secret Service about
missing January 6th text messages we've
received a huge amount of documents from
the Secret Service and have learned some
additional things so we plan to present
what we found out working through this
summer I think it will shed some light
on the events of the day and the events
leading up to it
the house January 6 committee has just
weeks remaining to finish its work and
issue its final report neither
Congressman McCarthy nor Senator Graham
returned requests for comment from CBS
news about their conversations with
officer Fanon
so there you have it and we're going to
be covering that January 6th select
hearing that
um Scott is talking about there it is
this Thursday
um our coverage will begin at noon
Eastern an hour before the hearing which
will begin at one Eastern so make sure
you tune in here or on the mind of touch
Network as we have brought you the
coverage of those hearings from the very
beginning we will continue to bring you
the coverage from those hearing to this
very important to our democracy that
anyone and everyone sees this evidence
including maybe this tape and the tapes
that they would play what did you make
of the Lindsey Graham and he's like you
should have just shot them in the head
yeah that's okay that is uh that's
that's crazy because here's the thing
they did shoot someone
and the right went [ __ ] crazy be like
oh actually Batman is she wasn't doing
anything
so you got you've got an elected
official who was also under
investigation for this Georgia uh 2020
election case it's all connected
um and you've got this guy saying
Lindsey Graham saying oh you guys should
have done your job which was shoot them
in the head so so that was the solution
just to shoot everyone in the [ __ ]
head that came through the doors
like that is what he wants because
here's the thing
they only shot one person
and they're already [ __ ] going out
and being like no no this is yeah they
want to jail they want to Jail the law
enforcement officer that was protecting
that didn't protect your area they're
like oh right so you shot this person
who was trying to commit more violence
against us and the elected officials
that we were protecting
inside of this building and so when we
did that then the right says oh no no no
this was murder tell us who did it uh
you know we want them to face charges
but then you've got this guy Lindsey
Graham lady G over here trying to say
well actually they should have done you
guys should have shot him in the head
you guys should have shot him ahead so
what's wrong with that
pick a [ __ ] Lane here which one is it
it's either you don't want them to do
their job and protect you or you do want
them to do the job and protect you like
you which is you don't want it you do
want it you want them to shoot someone
you don't want them to shoot someone wow
you know earlier when we were talking to
fake Gabe and he's like oh illegals are
voting but they're not voting because
they're striking it down it really is
something and if you're looking for
logic in this in this line of thinking
you're you're going to be lost
um speaking of lies and crime here is um
here is Grandpa Poopypants it appears to
me in this clip he's just admitting that
he committed crime Gabe huh yeah the
whole this whole [ __ ] rally was just
him being like uh
I'm the crime King let's listen
they don't get enough credit by contrast
I had a small number of boxes in storage
at Mar-A-Lago Garden
okay so he just said
into a microphone
confirming
that he had a small number I mean I
guess it depends on what your comparison
of you know a stack of boxes is but he's
admitting that he had a small number of
of documents boxes of documents stored
at Mar-A-Lago that's what I heard is
that what you heard because that's what
I heard it sounds like
he had boxes that he shouldn't have had
in storage yeah
let's continue let's see if he says
anything else about these boxes that by
secret service and my people and
everybody I mean it's safe when you look
at
these other people what they did and the
FBI raided my home and violated my
fourth amendment rights and many other
rights
because he just said they that he these
Republicans do this a lot they he he
said they now I'm guessing he's going to
tell us who they is here is this the
clip where he talks about former
presidents being
prosecuted let's let's continue let's
continue how they should go violent
because what are you saying here is they
violated my rights so he should they
should go violate their rights I think
is what he's saying let's listen and
under the Sox decision this is a very
important decision that was made they
call it the Sox decision because again
it had to do with Bill Clinton and his
socks
there is no crime you know there is no
crime it's not a crime
and they should give me immediately back
everything that they've taken from me
because it's mine it's mine
they took it from me in the raid they
broke into my house
but you know the good news is it's not a
break-in when they get a warrant that's
not the clip I was looking for but he
does start to talk about the Bill
Clinton thing there yeah um where he's
again it was a search warrant that was
legally signed approved executed by the
FBI because
uh you know Trump
stole documents lied about having the
documents lied about giving the
documents back that going back and forth
for a while and then when they said guys
okay can we just stop with this [ __ ]
we're just gonna come in and get it they
come in and get it and then Trump says
oh whoa whoa whoa this is
you guys are going through my [ __ ] why
are you going through my [ __ ] who said
you could go through my stuff you know
the other thing is confusing to me
though too is that if it's all his and
they're supposed to give it back
they either they it's either all his and
he had them there or they planted it I I
can't again it's the whole
double-sided both sides of the fence
thing I'm playing a video here for for
folks on the audio version so you're not
going to be able to see this this is an
actual pan of the um the sandbox here
the kitty litter box
that they were having the rally in oh
look at all the empty chairs there oh I
I my Wonder is
how many of these people do they pay
plane tickets for to come to these I
don't know I just love them dozens of
people isn't it isn't it great to see
the dough yeah well it look you know on
on camera it looks like a lot of people
because they they tightly pack them in
behind and they frame it I mean any
politician will do that but let's call
out the
the LIE of it was a packed house oh you
know what actually I think I got a text
message yeah from uh either did Don Jr
send you another text let's see I know
while he's looking for that text message
if you look here on the screen you can
see that what Gabe's talking about how
they pack people on bleachers behind
um and then there's a lot of space in
between a lot of space all right so I
got a text message actually uh let's see
I got one on Saturday that was saying
thank you that rally it goes on Saturday
he's having a pres Trump's rally rally
is epic what else do you want to hear
him speak about we need you to submit in
10 minutes and then you submit some
answers but you're supposed to give
topics or something yeah I guess so q a
type thing yeah but it's like what do
you want to hear him speak about I think
of the next one which was then going to
be in Arizona but again you click the
link crowd surfing ideas for him yeah
yeah and they're like election lock her
up you know then he does another one
that says press Trump thank you America
I just left off the rally stage I'm
reviewing a printed donor list soon
10x impact they don't understand how
[ __ ] the like multiplier impact works
okay because what they're claiming
is that when you donate
we will also find a donation to 10x that
right
the guy doesn't have any money so when
he claims oh you donate a hundred bucks
then we'll 10x that to make it a
thousand bucks it's just like a buzzword
to them now right exactly well I mean I
mean here's the thing he knows he knows
what gets these people to give them
money well yeah I mean totally but
that's why they all that's why it all
sounds the same right I mean it's
exactly like when he was like oh I'm
gonna Sue CNN but in order to do it I
need your money right like he literally
sent that last week and he was like I'm
suing CNN for defamation I'm a
billionaire yeah I'm the great king
billionaire that has all this money I'm
so successful but I need your money to
see them because I'm [ __ ] broke right
it really is weird it's almost it's
almost like he's full of [ __ ] but the
last almost like that I mean I got I got
a few I got dude I so many I got three
on Sunday but the one that I want to
bring out is he says
um press Trump Colin did you watch my
big rally it was one of my best yet I'm
extending your 10x impact for one more
hour and then you call them have the 10x
impact yeah yeah it's either 7x or 10x
they just make the [ __ ] number up oh
I got you so basically 20x I mean 100.
at least when I get the text thousand X
sounds really cool at least at least
when I get these text messages from uh
Frank speech AKA Mike Lindell oh uh it's
just a bunch of him having a bunch of
three-piece bath sets like if we get to
it here I can get to the Mike Lindell
clip I want to play this this is this is
Trump
um talking about
the former presidents of the United
States making sure even the Dead one he
wants to prosecute a dead president I'm
not [ __ ] you let's listen
I believe that what do you think yes yes
Mike
when will they investigate and prosecute
Bill Clinton Hillary Clinton George Bush
should look into what took place with
George Bush's father a very nice man and
the warehouse of documents and what
about Barack Hussein Obama are they
under potential prosecution I don't
think so I don't think they are
a Chinese restaurant even the crowd
isn't biting I don't think they are
Donald Trump should we go after like I
did the idea that he's like
he's like are they going are they going
after them I don't think so they should
go after George H.W bush like Jesus
Christ man this guy
wants to post humorously
say hey we should we should make this
guy uh you know I don't know a a
criminal a prisoner like I don't know
what his logic is by going after this
person
I mean yeah George H.W bush and George
Bush didn't do great things
but he's managed HW Bush is dead you
cannot exactly right you cannot
prosecute a dead person I mean you could
have you could maybe hold like maybe
maybe what he wants to do is hold a mock
trial like in high school and you're
like this person's on trial I got it I
got it I got it maybe just maybe if we
can figure out a way to for him to
understand that a dead person a dead
former president cannot be prosecuted
for federal crimes even ones that you've
stole documents and tried to steal an
election maybe we can get him to just
eat 14 15 buckets of chicken a day I
mean you know
to speed along the process I'm just
saying right right speaking of speaking
of um people who need to take a dirt nap
uh
I'm just saying what what what it would
be great Mike Lindell if he knew that
dead people can't be pressed get it
maybe I just saying okay now I wanna I'm
not gonna play a lot of this clip I
don't need to play a lot of this clip
because this is Mike Lindell appearing
in a parking lot somewhere yeah I've got
something to say about it in Nevada I'm
not gonna play a lot of but let's listen
to the garbly [ __ ] that comes that he
shits at his pillow let's let's listen
and uh January 15th everybody I had the
evidence but I also had a piece of paper
that was very important it's a
government gag order on this information
Dennis Montgomery was under his stuff is
under a gag order right right you can't
a gag order okay okay here's the thing
have you ever have you ever like went to
a post office and and tried to well I
mean and tried to like mail a package
and there's a guy standing on the
sidewalk like just saying all kinds a
crazy [ __ ] because at a post office it's
it's it's normally Federal property and
when you're on the public sidewalk you
had the right to stand there and say
crazy ass [ __ ] just whatever you want
whatever kind of crazy [ __ ] that comes
out of your your skull you can just puke
it up right there on the sidewalk that's
what this reminds me of like he is
literally like he's gotta have like five
people like yeah go Mike
go Mike did you get your cell phone back
buddy and he's standing there yelling
into a microphone about some piece of
paper that he took to the White House or
some [ __ ] what in the [ __ ] is he talking
about here Gabe
I don't know but the first thing that
came to my I mean like it doesn't make
any sense a gag order a gig order here's
the thing the first thing that comes to
mind because this is not the first time
that Mike Lindell has these like little
little [ __ ] tiny stages where he
performs outside of the venue
Michael and Dell is this a stage this
looks like he's he yeah yeah this is a
flag yeah yeah it's a it's a little it's
like a little like one and a half foot
stage this is like a Jumbotron behind
him then yeah yeah I thought he would I
thought he was like behind behind the
stage with like uh he's off to the side
so okay all right this is the way to
look at it
you know when you go to like a a musical
festival right and you're like all right
to see the main show right you go to
this stage
to see these one-off small ass acts
right you go over here or or better yet
when you go to a comedy show right I
mean I don't know how many conservatives
that do go to a comedy show but when
they got a video to show you we're going
to go along today can you go on can you
go along because I gotta go I got videos
exactly well it was kind of setting you
up for that but here so this is what I
will say Michael and Dell reminds me of
the comedian who goes to a comedy show
he's performing at a venue and they're
like all right at the main stage we've
got let's say Dave Chappelle right and
on the side room the little room that's
got like a bar where people mainly go in
to get drinks but don't actually listen
to the comedian there and it's got like
maybe two tables
that is where Michael and Dell shows up
so he's like not even the opener he's
not even the [ __ ] opener for the main
act he's off on the side in some other
room that nobody really knows about but
they go in and they just think oh with
just kind of some there's some live
entertainment but they don't know the
person's a comedian they come in there
to get a drink That's Mike Lindell you
just happen to have to pass him to get
what you want and here he is off to the
side before these ever take place he's
always out there outside the building or
outside of this like this litter box
where he is
trying to do his act and be like oh well
the FBI got this and this and that and
all this dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] but that
is that is Michael Lindell and that's
what he does at these rallies maybe he
just reminds me inside it just reminds
me of the guy that you stand at my post
office in my town he used to have a big
sign and it said all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
and it always said different crazy [ __ ]
like he would change it up at least like
Mike Lindell never changes the crazy
he's always got the same crazy I mean
the crazy guy at my post office would
have different signs and it would be
different crazy [ __ ] and like when you'd
walk by he's like yeah you know what I'm
talking about you're like yeah sure do
gonna go mail a package buddy but that's
just that's just how this goes Valerie
says here yes Tony we can go along today
and every day
I think she's hinting at something here
um I want to show you this do you use
talk about a comedian going to a comedy
show and Maga not really understanding
how comedy shows work
um this is from aerial comedy I think
her what's her last name I I um Ariel
Elise Elise is that her last name I
believe Lisa but she's at a comedy club
I'm not really sure where this is at
it's in New Jersey it's in New Jersey
okay yeah yeah so it's confirming it is
in New Jersey
um I've watched this a couple times
because it's [ __ ] hilarious yeah but
someone throws a beer can at her and
specifically they throw beer cans at her
because she voted Gabe listen listen
she voted for Joe Biden but also the
thing that's that people will see here
that's really important to know is she
doesn't bring it up right she she's like
oh people voted people voted like I'm
not like the the person in the audience
is the one that is instigating this to
come out and she dunks him in the trash
so perfectly let's listen
[Music]
why would you ask me that in here and
now I am the only Jew in this room
are you trying to get me killed
and it makes you feel any better I go to
New York my vote doesn't matter it
doesn't matter here either it doesn't
matter guys everybody vote for whoever
you want to vote I don't I don't care
who you voted for I'm just happy we're
all here together you are provided
I want to pause it there because she's
trying to say hey I'm here you paid
money yeah to come see me do a comedy
show not a show that you like to watch
on Trader TV where you watch all these
Carnival barkers like Lindell and and
tuberville and Trump and all these
Knuckleheads get on stage and say this
crazy outlandish [ __ ] that's not what
I'm here to do I'm here to make you make
you laugh not really make you angry
um and and this this lady won't give up
just won't give up on this like she's
like all right cool like we're gonna
just fuse the situation right now uh
everybody vote who you want to vote for
that should be the end of this
conversation well and she's kind of
given this this Heckler the out here
because what a lot of hecklers don't
understand about comedians
is generally they're really good writers
the best comedians are really good
writers and there's one thing that you
don't want to challenge in a room
with the person has the mic the
microphone be
eping on someone then you are it really
doesn't make a lot of sense like the
idea to Heckle a comedian when they're
the one with the microphone and they're
the one with the skill to absolutely
dump on you yeah um it doesn't make a
lot of sense but and it doesn't turn out
well for this Heckler either so much so
they get so pissed off they start
throwing things watch
but
[Applause]
again it is not a good idea yeah it is
not a good idea to be in a comedy club
where the best probably one of the best
writers in the room to dunk on you
is standing in the front with a
spotlight on them with a [ __ ]
microphone yeah it's probably either on
the person who has the mic who has the
power now right now like it just
it it's it honestly is something where
you probably again you know she offered
her the out she said everyone vote who
you want to vote for
we didn't want she did not put in power
she didn't say who she voted for she was
like why did you even ask the question
how is that even relevant here ready to
move on and not have to dump on that I
gotta know I I'm working on a joke here
and you keep asking me about [ __ ] who
I voted for
and and she so so greatly
undoes this person and you see the room
erupt now even with this room erupting
with that joke the person you would
think that person who just got dunked on
with the truth would shut the [ __ ] up
yeah but in true Maga style in true
manga fashion they just don't know when
they lost they just don't know
and it continues and she has to prove
again that the room does not want her to
talk let's listen
all right Make Some Noise if you wanted
to shut up
[Applause]
but I did ask if anybody had any
questions
that's on me that was on me for thinking
I could have a human interaction with
somebody
here I'll tell you I'll tell you the
rest of that bit and then and then we'll
move on I'm so insecure I went and got
an ID
oh yeah
now what you just saw there I don't know
if you noticed it or heard it
but someone and apparently it was a male
it was not the lady who was talking
um I thought it was probably her at
first but if you go read
um this comedian's thread on this it was
it was a dude that threw the beer so
probably one of the one of the trumped
up white news is this they're also Manga
girl was they've I I think the last I
heard this morning or last night I
forgot one was they well they were
looking because this is assault let's
just say this is assault what this what
this guy did right and I'm trying to
remember if they said they had them in
custody or if they were looking for them
yeah they were investigating them I
believe at least yeah again assault this
person through a beer can right pretty
hard as it hits the wall and splatters
it obviously was it was intended yeah
right now here's the best part about
this whole thing
she does not she does not quit the jokes
here nope it gave most comedians would
be like okay I'm done I'm gonna walk off
stage watch what she does with the beer
this is the most beautiful part about
this entire clip
are you [ __ ] kidding me
anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for those of you just listening she
picks up the beer and chugs that
[ __ ] yeah because she's badass
[ __ ] and really honestly um I
didn't think about this until just now I
should have
um messaged her she is welcome on the
show I'd love to talk to her about this
yeah like what actually happened she
also I don't know if you saw the tweets
that were happening yesterday she
tweeted out uh or Jimmy Kimmel had quote
tweeted and shared the video yeah and
she was like hey can I make my late
night debut on your show and he said yes
so I don't know what's going to happen
sweet I don't know when it's gonna
happen it's pretty good
you know hey look she swung for the
fences and either she strikes out or she
hits a [ __ ] home run you know you
know what's funny but Kim was like yeah
sure come on the show because I I
actually told you this in a tweet
because I think you tweeted it out dude
I tweeted it out it said something and
like you did too and I actually uh I
think you or I sent it to you I don't
remember
um you know me and Gabe are really sexy
oh you sent you sent it to me on
Instagram and I had seen it on Tick Tock
that's what it was
um here's the thing because I think
that's where I saw it was Instagram
first and then I gained it I don't
remember anyways the point is this
forget about me and Gabe having our
private
them intimate conversations with each
other and DMS and text messages here's
what I'll tell you that
the person who decided to try to make a
fool out of her in the club because she
voted for Biden and she thought it would
be popular and really cool for her to
point that out at that moment and make a
fool out of the person who had the
microphone who has the professional
skills to dump on someone in the crowd
like that's a that's a thing comedians
actually do like it's a skill that they
they try to work on
um she thought that it would be funny to
do it in that moment
and that person that that Trump
supporter that [ __ ] idiot made her
famous possibly yeah
um and and really honestly just because
that comedian was willing to lift that
clip and post it on social media and go
look at this idiot look at this idiot
but I think more importantly about that
clip
is folks these are the people that they
want to elect
these are the people that they want to
elect where I don't get my way and I you
you have a different political view than
me so we're going to take over and we're
going to take power and we get to take
control over you and what you're doing
because that's really what the the
audience member was trying to do was
take over and control her show because
she didn't like her jokes because she
could tell she voted for Joe Biden it's
probably because she's a decent human
being that's probably why she knew that
she would vote for Joe Biden is because
she's decent she's not a [ __ ] scumbag
but listen to this scumbag because as
much as important as it is to know that
that lady who is in that comedy club
doing that she's gonna vote and you have
to go vote to cancel her vote and you
have to get other people to vote to make
sure you win we win
listen to what this scumbag this Maga
scumbag says on stage
about
when they don't win elections what
they're going to do is this the greatest
president in American history or not
[Applause]
okay first off that's really gross
that's really gross
I mean we we all we all know we all know
who is the greatest president in
American history and it's definitely
it's definitely not Donald Trump but
let's let's continue
[Music]
so we have something in common president
Trump and I lost an election in 2020
because of a rigged election
I've been working since November 4th
2020 to expose what happened and what I
found out is horrifying and when I'm
Secretary of State of Nevada we're going
to fix it and when my Coalition of
Secretary of State candidates around the
country get elected we're going to fix
the whole country and president Trump is
going to be president again at 2024.
[Applause]
foreign
okay folks I don't know if you got that
I know the clip might be a little
um silent there because the audio from
Trader TV News Network sucks ass but
here's what I'll tell you here's their
plan and they're saying it out loud and
again believe them when they tell you
this
they have a plan at 2022 to take the
house and they want to take the Senate
and if that doesn't work then they'll
get secretary's estate all around the
country elected so they can fix your
vote
he used the word fixed in other words
you don't vote the way we want you to
vote we will just make it so that we
decide which is not a thing that happens
in constitutions
it's not a thing that happens in
Constitution just like our constitution
does not allow the vice president of the
United States to Crown a king
when there's certification of the
state's votes
for the Electoral College that's not a
thing that happens there is no
constitutional mechanism that gives the
Secretary of State in any state
any state the ability to overturn an
election unilaterally just because they
don't like the outcome that is not a
[ __ ] thing
they don't care though they do not care
they don't care that these things exist
because here's what they know here's
what I think is happening Gabe
they know Congress is going to do
something about January 6. what I mean
by that is they they are going to pass a
piece of legislation that makes it very
clear that the vice president of the
United States does not have unira
unilateral authority to overturn an
election during the certification of the
uh Electoral College votes that were
certified by the states they are going
to probably pass a piece of legislation
especially if you folks go out and vote
and you win the Senate and we keep the
house there is going to be a piece of
legislation that Joe Biden is going to
sign making sure and this only makes
sense that the to make it clear so we
don't have vice president Mike Pence
running around trying to ask Dan Quayle
if this idea that a vice president can
overturn an election is true
they're going to pass a piece of
legislation that will prevent that they
know that in 2024 they will not have the
opportunity because number one Kamala
Harris will be the vice president okay
and if it is what they say it is then
Kamala Harris can just make herself for
our Obama or or Joe Biden the kids and
then tell tell the audience who takes
over if if Harris isn't the vpu and then
becomes the president who's next on the
list
that what you mean you mean you mean the
speaker of the house oh okay okay so so
here's the thing they're gonna pass this
piece of legislation and they know in
2024 Kamala Harris is going to be the
vice president they know that I don't
care what they say they're gonna impeach
or whatever they're not winning this
election the reason why is because they
would you know how many seats they would
have to win to get 60 votes to impeach
Biden or Harris you dumb [ __ ]
you act like we hadn't done two
impeachments in the last goddamn [ __ ]
four years of the last [ __ ]
you have to have 60 votes to remove
someone
it doesn't matter how many [ __ ]
impeachments the [ __ ] house votes for
it doesn't matter they have to have 60
votes to remove a president or a vice
president or a speaker or a attorney
general whoever the [ __ ] they're going
to try they're gonna try to impeach all
kinds of people if they become if they
get the house now
they know 2024 there's only one way to
do a violent Insurrection game there's
only one way there's only one and it's
it's at the state election levels that's
before the vote gets certified that is
where their plan is for the next
Insurrection folks they're saying it out
loud they're saying it out loud that
they are going to make sure that they
have secretaries in place so they can
unilaterally overturn elections and that
way they can have their band of
miscreants come and create violence at
the capitals and the places they need to
create violence at to make sure that
when they send the Electoral College
votes to Washington to be certified by
Congress that it's the way that they
need it that is their plan their plan
and you must stop them and the way that
you stop them it's not just voting for
your house member you're represented for
the house or your Senate in a state that
has to Senate election you have to vote
for Governors you have to vote for
Secretary of State all the way down to
the God damn dog catcher you need to
have pro-democracy candidates that
you're voting for that is super
important here because they're telling
you their plan they're playing long game
here because Donald Trump may be locked
in a federal prison somewhere but
they're not gonna give a [ __ ] they don't
care about the rules they don't care
about the Constitution they don't care
about reality and Truth they don't give
a [ __ ] their main goal is for Donald
Trump to be crowned King so that he can
he can create a fascist state that is
their [ __ ] goal am I wrong here am I
no no no I mean they want to do whatever
they can to control the outcome of the
election to control any position they
want to run for because they have a
moment of uh uh you know we've had this
we've had power for so long or we've had
a taste for even more power I mean I
actually talk about I think it's coming
out tomorrow but it'll be the it's
finished and done it's the what was that
a Herschel Walker and at the end of the
day when you look at these controversies
that come forward because of moments
with with Herschel Walker which is like
oh it's not only revealed he had secret
children but then he lied about paying
for an abortion then he lied about lying
about paying for an abort like
even with all these things you're like
whoa boy this guy is a is a hot mess of
controversy we probably don't want him
involved because there's probably more
stuff that's going on behind the scenes
that we don't even know about right now
but you've got Rick Scott Ted Cruz
Lindsey Graham Donald Trump uh uh Greg
Kelly like all these people uh Dana Loch
they don't care about who the person is
and what they've done they only care
about the power they don't care about
human lives They Don't Care About The
Unborn they don't care about these
babies right because the Herschel Walker
it's only a 700 check
and uh
and uh in a little cheap four dollar get
well card right so like if he sinned you
would get well card do you have a
relationship I know you have a
relationship with Christian Walker but
you sent me a get well card and he was
like uh hey uh don't be so mean to me in
this what was that okay uh please get
one okay so it wasn't something else
when you point something out here on
YouTube she says because they can't win
without cheating Wendy it goes much
further than that cheating lying killing
stealing whatever it goes much further
than them cheating cheating would imply
that they actually are going to try to
make sure that elections are done up in
a way they tried that and it didn't work
with gerrymandering they didn't get the
gerrymandering map that they counted on
they literally are telling you if we if
you elect us these Secretary of States
us fascist nazi secretaries estate
if you elect us what we will do is
ignore the Constitution ignore our oath
and we will make Donald Trump the king
of this country yeah that is what
they're saying and they say well beyond
cheating that is well beyond cheating
they're like oh the Maga King the Maga
King it's like oh boy the only King that
Donald Trump is actually a king of is
Burgers okay he is he is a Burger King
yeah I'm not saying I'm not saying he's
the Burger King I'm saying he's a Burger
King the guy eats more fast food and and
burgers than I well then I honestly know
like probably more than the guy from
Super Size Me but Donald Trump is I mean
he's eating himself to death so whatever
I don't really care well here's the
thing is that his his Cola we we see the
crowd there when we watch the video of
the crowd in in Arizona how small it was
yeah how flaccid it was
um and that's the most dangerous part
about this is he's getting down to the
crazies of the crazy who are loyalists
and that's the real danger here
um people like this lady here are gonna
go vote so my question is
are you let's listen
Donald Trump is the president of the
1776 president
so the 13 colonies would that be the 13
colonies yes that's what it's going back
to Obama is playing
sleepy Joe Biden
in a mask George Woods the actor is
playing sleepy Joe trying to wake people
up
by pretending to spend all this money in
Ukraine that he signs and he's signing a
blank paper
all right Tupac still alive yep where's
he Jackson is still alive where are they
and there were trouble well they're in
the and I'm we're out here damn it I
would have loved to have seen Tupac I'll
show you a picture I don't believe in
the climate even even after seeing like
the hurricanes and and the floods and
the erosion well have you heard of harp
where they can control our weather
so do you think our weather is being
controlled oh yeah
Biden is just a puppet he's being he's
being manipulated from the top by whom
he's the top though right deep State
he's not the top he's just a puppet who
would tell me about the Deep sale of it
so who would that be an unknown faction
of
um people that are this new world order
you know that's what it is they're
trying to uh get the whole world
into a reset to their demands
you know and where are these are these
people in America are they in other
countries it could be anywhere they're
rich I mean they I don't mean the rich
per se but
the Deep state
[Music]
I don't we don't even know who they are
I mean but you're convinced that they
exist yes I am
are you a subscriber to Q Anon
um so their theories about this stuff
too
yes and do you think they're going to be
a factor in the 2024 election absolutely
what makes you say that like what how do
you have that inkling now two two years
ahead
well the the drops tell us everything
and it's all playing out publicly
um oh God
okay
I just want to point I just want to
point something out okay they talk about
HARP right
now I mean the weather thing yeah yeah
yeah so the harp is the high frequency
active
rural research program okay this thing
was shut down in 2014.
the equipment was transferred to the
University of Alaska uh Fairbanks in
August 2015. this program is no longer
in existence okay okay listen listen to
me
they think Tupac and Michael Jackson are
still alive my friend I don't know Tupac
still makes Tupac is is releasing albums
out of the Vault from the brave see what
happens is they recorded his voice and
once you have the recording you can
um play it back you can even put it on
an album you can even release it when
anime release look folks the point of me
playing that clip is this
these [ __ ] that you just heard
say the craziest [ __ ] that you've just
[ __ ] hurt hey this is Jonestown type
[ __ ] yeah they are gonna go [ __ ] vote
count on it and they are going to take
people with them to go vote
are you listening it is up to you it is
up to you to save our democracy from
these [ __ ] boneheads because there
are people out there that are complacent
to this stuff and like ow these people
aren't that crazy these Trump supporters
aren't that crazy I'll still vote for
Republicans because they're really not
going to take our rights like you say
they're yes they are yes they are they
are coming for you and your way of life
imagine imagine being in a q Anon world
just living in it imagine because folks
to some degree that is where we are at
this is a q Anon World we're just
[ __ ] living in it so it's up to you
it is your choice right now you've got
four weeks
four weeks
not just your vote your friends your
family I implore you check your
registration get three other people to
check their registration and and get
them to get three other people to check
your registration it will at least get
their mindset that hey I have to do this
thing it is vitally important because we
can't just win we have to pile them in
mountains of votes in Florida in Georgia
in Texas in Pennsylvania in Ohio in
Missouri in Nevada in Arizona you're
hearing it right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast it is do or die at this
point for our democracy they are
hellbent on taking it away from you not
just cheating you in an election they
are going to steal your democracy and
take it down they are going to take away
your rights that you have the way of
life that you know they want to get rid
of it dunk it in the trash
that so much so that they are willing to
say things like oh yeah Secretary of
States even though it's not in
constitutions we'll just overturn
elections if we don't like the outcome
if we don't like your vote we will just
do the opposite of that because that
sounds like democracy but folks these
people think that harp exists they think
that [ __ ] Michael Jackson and they
think that Tupac Shakur is is in in bed
with Donald Trump to take over the world
and their Q anon's gonna have something
just listen to the drops I'm telling you
it is a moment in history right now this
next four weeks is a moment in history
that will determine whether we have a
democracy going forward and it's up to
you it really is up to you now everyone
thanks for joining us today even
sticking around long for some of these
clips that we had
make sure that you go to the chip jar we
run on your support Tony Michaels dot
live you can give a one-time tip or you
can set it up monthly we appreciate
everyone who gives the tips there at
tonymichaels.live everyone's been liking
this shirt oh yeah yeah sure the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty it's the Liberty shirt and I
put the Liberty coffee mug up too and
everyone really likes the Liberty coffee
mug as well so I mean gosh how you start
your morning you know fresh fresh pot of
Liberty fresh pot of Liberty hot hot hot
and ready so go to
store.dtonymichaels.com go to
store.thetonymichaels.com to find all
your Liberty merch I also got the um
I did lock her up we did a lock her up
design on there so if you want to lock
her up um coffee mug or shirt it's or
lock him up sorry lock him up but yeah
I'm getting it confused because someone
on YouTube said do a dig her up design
I
the Digger up design is doing better
than the lock camera design yeah well I
mean I didn't have that card really well
here here's the thing when you find out
that there are still right still missing
documents everyone's like all right
where are they there's got to be in the
other homes I mean uh Cohen told us on
the show that the documents are are
hidden elsewhere right if they're in if
they're in one spot in Mar-A-Lago
they're guaranteed to be in other
locations that he owns but also I mean
we've everyone has been wondering why
there are 10 ball uh uh ball bear or
Paul bearers why they were why there was
uh not six like normally she was
cremated but they had a coffin so it's
like why were that many hands needed to
carry something that was you know
relatively light in actual practice
because it's possible that there are
documents in there now I I think popoc
said because it's a private property
they can't actually exhume the body but
I don't know how that works for
something like this I'm not sure well
I'll tell you that the Dig her up shirt
is going hung wild over there so go
check it out I don't have a I wasn't
prepared to uh I didn't know how popular
it was gonna be but the Digger up shirt
over on store that the Johnny
michaels.com is going like hotcakes as
they watch cakes hotcakes so go go check
out the the Liberty shirts the Rhonda
santis can go [ __ ] himself we have dank
Brandon everyone was saying our dank
Brandon design was spot on so go check
that on a store store.jodymichaels.com
and um if a dig her up shirt is your is
your go then head over there head over
there everyone tomorrow same time same
place and remember remember this week
groundbreaking news Thursday our
coverage will start at our show time
noon Eastern 11 Central nine Pacific is
when our coverage will start of the
January's Excel six select hearings
tune in
until tomorrow same time in the same
place Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon